[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre cette ut
wazir avec vous retrouver pour 13
minutes d'idées sorties le sommaire de
ce jeudi 11 avril l'instant des
tout-petits de retour dans les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis le 6 avril continue
lecture de contes et spectacles pour
bourbon un rythme le programme de
babillages laurence canto la responsable
du festival sera sur notre plateau
depuis le mois de janvier les enfants
des centres de loisirs de bois d'arcy
elancourt oui en cours et maurepas
réfléchisse à leur installation sur la
lune restitution des projets
scientifiques de ces apprentis
astronautes ce samedi lors de l'after
légaux ligue junior
le musée il sans laurent à paris ressort
des placards sa collection automne hiver
2009 165 celle de la fameuse robe
mondrian inspirée du peintre abstrait de
la peinture à la mode nous décrirons
cette exposition en fin d'émission le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'oublie pas
les petits toute l'année des lectures de
contes sont organisées aux sondés
racontines et depuis sept ans les
bambins ont même leur festival babillage
il a démarré le 6 avril grégory canale a
assisté à l'un des spectacles
aujourd'hui on va faire chanter love un
phrasé et des mots adaptés un public
bien particulier dans la salle le plus
jeune à trois mois ce spectacle entre
dans le cadre du festival baby âge un
rendez vous dédié à la petite enfance
on trouve très peu de spectacle sur la
petite enfance certains parents
imaginent que les enfants le livre ne
sommes pas parlés
le livre n'est pas important pour eux
alors qu'on se rend compte à chaque fois
que ça éveille du tas de choses des
comptines qui capte l'attention des
petits poissons de la médiathèque de la
verrière
c'est un spectacle vraiment fonctionne
avec des tout petits au départ les les
gens n'y croient pas trop quand il les
emmène mais ça fonctionne vraiment un
spectacle pour parler environnement mais
aussi la toute-puissance la fontaine aux
grenouilles finit par ne plus obéir aux
deux comédiens des détails qui ne va pas
augmenter
je suis de suite de chutes de judo alors
on était très très agréablement surpris
en fait puisqu'on n'était pas trop sur
la réaction des enfants et ils ont été
scindés temps et les prix dans la magie
du spectacle et
ce sens ils ont apprécié un éveil à
l'imaginaire pour cet instant des
tout-petits organisé par le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis sept ans lorsqu'en taux
directeur du festival a rejoint plateau
bonjour bonjour alors on l'a vu dans le
reportage b bat visage ça propose des
spectacles de 0 à 3 ans on peut donc
amené son bébé de voir un spectacle où
elle est là c'est avec plaisir que je
regarde encore les petites captures de
ce spectacle en effet et des parents
avec des bébés de 3 6 9 10 mois qui
s'était collée à la porte pour être sûr
que si jamais le bébé se met à pleurer
ou à crier ou avoir peur il pouvait
partir en vitesse et la personne ne les
a vu repartir et on a un temps dû en
effet les des petits babillage on a
entendu des comme ça et on m'avait les
enfants de 2 ans et demi qui éclaté de
rire en fait c'était vraiment pour tous
les niveaux et les parents pour y avait
toujours une petite note d'humour aussi
qui rappelait les parents et ils sont
sortis en disant mais c'est un régal
d'humour de poésie de magie et notre
enfant a tenu coi c'était c'était
vraiment plaisant parce que là les
comédiens y travaille beaucoup sur la
sonorité mais cette année la thématique
c'est aussi la gestuelle
vous avez une phrase quand les petites
mains anonymes du geste à la comptine
voile c'était pour être en relation avec
l'action culturelle qui était sur le
corps et le mouvement avec les tout
petits corps en mouvement où il la
motricité le spectacle mais les petites
mains s'anime en fait cette
manifestation à se tourner autour des
comptines et des histoires à doigts et
aussi sur le français signé en appui de
l'oralité et on va voir aussi bien les
ateliers pour les parents sur le
français signer mais aussi des jeux de
comptines et on a eu il ya deux jours
une conférence qui était formidable avec
raph nataf un grand conteur qui nous a
scotchés dans la précision du mot et la
narration faite de ces histoires à
doigts en avait aussi martin bourque est
une grande illustratrice donc ça a mené
une centaine de personnes tous des
professionnels petite enfance en fait on
essaye de celui des petites graines
aussi bien vers les parents bien sûr les
enfants on les cultive mais aussi
vers les professionnels qui eux sont en
charge des tout petits
7ème édition le festival la piste en
science devient un grand parent et on
répond présent à chaque fois oui oui oui
tous les spectacles affichent complet ou
alors voilà on avait quand même beaucoup
de listes d'attentes souvent les
spectacles pour les tout petits sont des
petites jauges la gav est quand même
deux comédiens s'étaient musicale y
avait un grand décor donc on a eu une
chose à 60 personnes ce qui est énorme a
fait 30 35 enfants plus les parents et
puis bon les autres spectacles sont des
fois plus modérée ou en a d'autres qui
sont formidables
les artistes qu'on a rencontrés dans le
reportage nous ont confié qu'ils étaient
ravis qu'un festival comme ça existe
c'est assez rare finalement un festival
de l'accident si ça commence un jeu il
ya les arsouilles aussi qui se font dans
le centre de la france j'ai été fait je
n'avais qu'un petit peu dans les
festivals pour piocher les pépites
voilà je vais un peu partout mais à
quinze jours consacrés aux livres à
l'album une histoire au spectacle vivant
pour les tout petits c'est formidable et
les parents vont arriver sont les
premiers à venir
on a un superbe programme on a la chance
d'avoir ce programme - mais il est très
très vite remplie justement on doit
présenter de trois spectacles qui reste
parce que c'est jusqu'au 20 avril
jusqu'au 20 avril
ils sont tous complets moi j'aime
beaucoup aussi le petit bonhomme de
chemin qui aura lieu samedi matin à
rousselot et samedi après-midi à
anatole-france satrape et là aussi c'est
à une épopée musicale une instrumentiste
musicienne chanteuse qui nous fait à la
fois des comptines qui utilise tout un
tas d'instruments et ses instruments
font partie du décor avec une
ingéniosité qui a été encensé à sept
spectacles d'enfoncer musique donc
vraiment formidable merci florence quant
aux deux vernis sur notre plateau dont
vous pouvez retrouver toute la
programmation du festival babillage sur
le site internet du réseau des
médiathèques
on reste dans la petite enfance avec
l'événement en attendant bébé ou mercure
hôtel de maurepas pour cette deuxième
édition des conférences des ateliers
dédiés aux futurs parents sont proposées
toute la journée avec même des soins
pour un instant bien être une fois
l'enfant née l'association les chants
des lunes vous propose d'apprendre à
utiliser vos cordes vocales et de les
accompagner avec
dans une coulée les pour interpréter des
comptines le stage youku bébé pour être
un papa ou une maman star de la berceuse
c'est ce dimanche 14 avril à elancourt
village pour pouvez vous inscrire via
leur adresse mail un grand enfant de
retour chez ses parents c'est là le
festival n'ont pas du tout festival mais
le rendez vous dans les salles de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
alors cette semaine aussi 17 un
programme assez complet je vais pas
détailler tous les films tanguy lé
retour le très attendu la très attendue
suite pardon d'étienne chatiliez avec le
même casting toujours andré dussollier
sabine azéma et eric berger voilà je
cherchais sont donc donc je n'ai pas
encore vu le film je peux pas vous en
parler mais il est à la fiche je vais
insister sur le très beau film qui
s'appelle c'est ça l'amour interprétée
par notre ami bouli lanners qu'on a eu
la chance de recevoir ici donc on à l
affiche aussi venez le découvrir en
salles cette semaine
et puis deux événements cette semaine
dans le cadre du festival contre champ
samedi à 16h30 si vous aimez les courts
métrages et là ce sont des courts
métrages sur la danse puisque le thème
du festival cette année c'est la danse
venez voter donc à 16h30 pour choisir
votre court-métrage préféré s'associent
dans deux autres salles des yvelines et
dimanche à 18h30 venez voir ou revoir
découvrir ou redécouvrir et faut
absolument voir ce très beau film de bob
fu ce all that jazz en français que le
spectacle commence donc avec rocher vers
18h30 dimanche et j'en profite profite
d'avoir la parole pour faire un petit
focus sur ce qui va se passer le
vendredi 19 avril à 20h30 aussi 17
nous recevons la réalisatrice de ce très
beau film qui s'appelle seul à mon
mariage
donc le 19 à 20h30 aussi 17 si vous
souhaitez la rencontrer
[Musique]
depuis le mois de janvier 15 enfants de
6 à 9 ans réfléchisse à comment vivre
sur la lune et participent au challenge
first lego league
juniors encadrés par l'association
ingenious et les centres de loisirs de
quatre communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
objectif préparer une base lunaire et un
robot adapté en lego et présenter son
projet à un jury lors de la rencontre
finale du samedi 13 avril vous pourrez
d'ailleurs il y assister et encourager
votre team de 14 heures à 18 heures à la
maison des associations lino ventura à
bois d'arcy
donc ils vont présenter devant un jury
bienveillant qui vont noter la démarche
mais chaque enfant la construction la
programmation les affiches à la manière
de présenter leurs projets et à cette
heure il est à la remise des médailles
est-ce que d'un facteur rencontre tout
le monde est gagnant tout le monde peut
venir tout le monde est invité au
contraire les soutenir votre équipe que
ce soit de la vidéo d'art ciment file
encore guyancourt au d'autres communes
possèdent la bienvenue la ville de
plaisir souhaite promouvoir
l'utilisation du vélo en ville pour cela
les roues et cadrans sont à l'honneur
les 12 et 13 avril prochains
des animations devant la gare plaisir
grignon le vendredi est un village du
vélo au château le samedi
vous pouvez retrouver le programme
complet sur le site internet de la ville
et notez également que la traditionnelle
jean racine la fête du vélo franciliens
à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse a lieu ce
week end des 13 et 14 avril au domaine
saint paul après un succès pour sa
première édition le semi-marathon de
trappes revient ce dimanche 14 avril un
vrai 21 km pour les plus entraînés un 10
km pour les débutants email une course
pour les enfants
pour l'occasion le stade gilbert son sac
propose des ateliers découverte
athlétique pour les enfants de 6 à 10
ans ils pourront s'initier à la course
aux lancers et au saut une fois n'est
pas coutume nous allons parler mode pour
votre briki sortie en ile de france
[Musique]
ouvert en octobre 2017 le musée hissant
laurent permis de découvrir l'univers du
célèbre créateur jusqu'au 31 décembre
c'est sa collection automne-hiver 1965
et présenté une collection célèbre pour
ses robes inspirées du peintre piet
mondrian reportage de miles kerhoas de
nos confrères via grand paris une coupe
moderne
l'utilisation du jersey le travail des
lignes et des couleurs
découvrez la pièce maîtresse de la
collection automne hiver 1965 d'yves
saint laurent
l'iconique robe mondrian entrer dans les
coulisses du défilé
grâce à des croquis des maquettes et des
échantillons avec yves saint laurent la
couture devient un art c'est une
collection où il décide de rendre
hommage à deux peintre piet mondrian et
serge poliakoff c'est à dire que saint
laurent va pour la première fois
s'intéresser à la transposition pictural
vers une rom c'est à dire qu'ils
commencent à concevoir en trois
dimensions une peinture en deux
dimensions ça a été quand même un déclic
si vous voulez dans l'histoire de la
mode c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment
commencé à considérer la mode comme un
art et ses anciens que saint laurent a
été extrêmement novateur ça laurent
voulait donner du pouvoir aux femmes en
leur attribuant les codes vestimentaires
des hommes ils s'appropriera la
combinaison le trench coat ou encore le
smoking il créera le choc des couleurs
en associant le bleu et le vert ou le
rouge et le rose pour comprendre le
processus créatif du couturier
rendez vous à l étage dans le studio
d'yves saint laurent deux fois par an il
alla marrakech et il dessinait pendant
quinze jours des centaines de dessins il
revenait il rassemblait ses
collaborateurs ses chefs d'atelier ici
même là où nous trouvons chacun
repartait juste au dessus les tâches du
dessus était consacrée aux ateliers
chacun revenait après un certain temps
avec ce qu'on appelle une toile le
mannequin rentrer par la porte qui est
juste au bout de cette pièce arrivé ici
saint laurent était assis à son bureau
regardez la toile toujours à travers
voir si le valider là on choisissait le
tissu la toile repartait dans les
ateliers et revenait portait toujours
sur un mannequin vivant taillé dans le
tissu un hommage au début d'un des
créateurs les plus originales de ce
siècle
à découvrir jusqu'au 31 décembre 2019
avant la présentation d'une nouvelle
collection et c'est la fin de ce numéro
le sait qui tu choisirais ce coming dg
du prochain bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oh